احب السفر والترحال وجماهما عشق التصوير
واستكشاف الطبيعه وتحدياتها امين عطيه
ونار العميره زوجان سعوديان يطوفان العالم
برا بدا ثنائي بدا رحلتهما عام 2015 عندما
قرران الارتباط وقضاء شهر العسل في رحله
بريه حول الولايات المتحده لمده شهرين في
العام الماضي شارك جمهورهما رحله 90 يوما
في استكشاف السعوديه ومناطقها المختلفه
وبعدها رحله في اوروبا
يصاحب ناره وامين جمهور عريض كجزء من
رحلتهما نجاح في تكوين صداقته عبر مشاركته
مع مقاطع فيديو قصيره
لمغامرتهما الممتعه على مواقع التواصل
عندما تستعد للسفر بالسياره يجب معرفه بعض
القواعد واهم المستلزمات التي لا غنى عنها
اولا يجب التخطيط الجيد للرحله وتحضير
البطانيه والاجهزه الالكترونيه وعليك ان
ترتبها بحيث يسهل الوصول اليها
واجب فحص السياره والتاكد من خلوها من
الاعطال ولا تنسى اخذ مفتاح احتياطي
لتشغيلها ولابد من التاكد من وجود منفاخ
هواء عده اصلاح كشاف وبالتاكيد نطفه حريق
اضافه لذلك يجب اخذ مستلزمات طبيه لسفريكا
بالسياره اهمها القطن والشاشه الطبيه
ومنادي المعقمه اضافه لادويه ومسكنه عامه
ومراهم الج
لد وفيما يخص الاغذيه يجب عدم تناول
الاطعمه التي تحتوي على الزيوت بالاحضار
المعلبات والفواكه التي لا تفسد سريعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نذهب الى الرياض الزوج الرحاله امين عطيه
الله ومن مكه الزوجه نار العميره يسعد
هالصباح يسعد هالصباح يا امين ونارا
يعطيكم الف عافيه اولا يعني كلها الاشهر
وهلايام وانتوا مع بعض في هالسياره في
حلكم وترحالكم اليوم شو سر هالفرقه يعني
الله يديم الوفاء بس شو اللي صار بالسياره
لا تفرقته ولا بلدين لمنطقتين
احنا بصراحه الان رجعنا السعوديه من كم
يوم فزيارات عائليه
انه بعد ما نرجع من السفر لازم نروح نشوف
اهلنا زي كده فانا اهلي في مكه اصلا
بس يعني السؤال هيك قبل ما نبلش ما تحكوا
لنا عن رحلتكم امين ونارا بالعاده بقولوا
انه في مشاكل البيت والمشاكل الزوجيه بتضل
داخل جدران المنزل يعني للبيوت اسرار هل
بالسياره يعني دائما الله يوفقكم مع بعض
ونحنا فاعل خير هل بالسياره وبهذي الاشهر
الطويله هيك اتوطدت العلاقه ولا قلتوا
يعني مشاكل البيت ارحم همم
مشاكل السياره
طيب امين ليش اخترته سياره تحديدا لقطع
هذه المسافات الطويله والانتقال بين
القارات ليش تحديدا السياره
من اكثر الاشياء الي نحن نحبها الاستكشاف
بالسياره ولما جربنا نفسنا مع بعض قد ايش
احنا نحب نقطع مسافات طويله في السياره
فقررنا انه السياره هي تكون طريقنا وطبعا
ليش سيارتنا لانه احنا تعبنا على تجهيزات
انه احنا نقدر في اي مكان نقدر نمشي في اي
مكان الحمد لله سيارتنا هي بالنسبه لنا
اغلى ما نملك حبيت السياره ولا تتمنى انه
الطياره وتوصلي بسرعه احسن لا بالعكس يمكن
انا اللي ال- ال- انا اللي كنت امين انه
احنا نسوي هذا الشيء صراحه انا من الناس
اللي تحبه الحال المسافات طويله همم يعني
همم
ما في احد يقدر يوصلها
طيب امين انا صار عندي فضول بس اعرف كيف
شكلها السياره وشو مواصفاتها ولا تقدر
تخليكم تسافروا اشهر من بلاد لبلاد
انا اعتقد انه اهم شيء يعني موجود عندنا
في السياره اللي هي اول حاجه سهوله الوصول
الى اغراضنا واشياءنا فاحنا مرتبينها
بطريقه ميسره ثاني حاجه انه يكون فيها
التجهيز اللي احنا نقدر نمشي فيه اه على
رمي على اسفلت على تكون رحلتنا واهم شيء
طبعا احنا عندنا خيبتنا الخاصه فينا فوق
السياره نقدر نفتحها في اي مكان احنا
موجودين فيه اه
اه ممكن هذه اهم الاشياء اللي ممكن اقول
عنها في السياره
وغير كده طبعا تحملنا وصبرنا لانه موضوع
انه احنا نمشي مسافات طويله ما هو حاجه
بسيطه انه اوكي يلا وخلاص لانه هذه الحاجه
قال وناره نحبها فاحنا مستمتعين واحنا
نشوف مناظر مختلفه اماكن طبيعيه مختلفه
ناس مختلفين بيوت عماير ففي اشياء كثير
تمر علينا احنا بنحاول نستمتع فيها جزء من
حياتنا بطريقه حلوه
بالحديث عن الحب والشغف في ايام فكرته
تستسلموا الا لو تشرحيلنا يعني المسار
لنفهم جغرافيا انتم كيف مشيتوا بالسياره
وين انا حجاوب على السؤال هذا بالجزئين
الجزء الاول هو بس لما بنرجع لسؤالك الاول
اللي هو تجهيز السياره كثير اتوقع لازم
تكون عندهم سياره خارقه علشان يقدر يسوي
رحله زي كده ولكن ابدا اي سياره عندكم
جدا صعب لانه اصلا المسافات الطويله
بالسياره مرهقه جدا
الجو مغترب الشمس
امين بدات المغامره من 2015 وبالسياره
زرتم عده مناطق في امريكا اوروبا وحتى في
السعوديه ما هي اكثر منطقه احببتموها انت
ونارام
طبعا كل منطقه او كل دوله لها انطباع
مختلف عن الثاني لها احاسيس لها مشاعر لان
بطبيعه المكان في كل مكان مختلف لكن اقدر
انه في كل مكان اقدر احصر لك انه في هذا
المكان مثلا في امريكا احنا همم انبسطنا
في همم صحراء ريزونو همم صحراء نيفادا طيب
في اسكتلن من اكثر الاماكن الجميله اللي
احنا عشنا فيها اسكتلندا طيب في السعوديه
انا ما اقدر احدد مكان معين لانه السعوديه
متميزه في كل مكان من الاماكن كلها في
طبيعتها يعني بامانه الحمد لله فضل الله
انه احنا كنا نحط هذه التجاره ونتعلم منها
ونشوف
اكيد احنا بنبشركم امينو نارا يعطيكم
العافيه وبالتوفيق دوما شكرا لكما